each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay good afternoon my name is Alexandra
deal as Stuart said i'm from argentina
from the computer science of the
university of buenos aires and today i
am going to present my work on 3d
geographical environments and use
spatial data exploration using flight
simulators and deer databases and the
diet of it's longer but i promise you
the presentation will be shorter the
this work consists in the integration of
three technologies geographical
databases flight simulators and
scientific visualization to do both a
analysis quantitative and qualitative
analysis this work could be enclose it
in the area of geographical this
visualization or do visualization that
has several several subjects of interest
the exploration of geographic phenomena
global climate changes also prevention
on environment disaster illogical
studies cetera and the integrative
process has three main parts the first
part involves the management on
iteration use information sources these
data sources could come from different
sides to come from Terran elevation data
to graphic information and neither do
spatial data sources like us GPS or
remote sensing and
we have to unify these iterations and
different formats and the second part of
this work involves the management of
this information this massive volume
data information and to put inside into
our database geographical data base and
the third part of the work is the
visualization and simulation of this
information the visualization is not
only to show data if not it consists in
explore data in the way the user can
indicate where to go and what you see
and we will try to achieve this using
flight simulators also i have another
eight and another two spatial data could
come from others applications directly
to the visualization system we have
between the both the two last part and
interface to create internal to create
entire a de scenes to the visual
application in this work we we use we
have used a data source coming from the
SRT on the shuttle radar topography
mission also Landsat images and we have
studied the weather data the climate
data from the national climatic data
center
and we we had a defining an interface a
unified format to manage this data
sources we have a study the standards
proposed by the opening special
consortium do the UGC proposed define
the open di di l standards and to
restore and to manage your spatial
information and and to change this just
spatial information between several
application and we have a study along
with the geographic market language that
this standard proposed here we have an
example this standard proposed to is to
use this language DML we could use
templates or also we could use profiles
here have a profile a point profile and
we could we could indicate the spiritual
reference system it consists in a epsg
code is there this code is defined by
the european petroleum server group that
has a a database with all the coordinate
systems and define also that this
coordinate system is at geographic
coordinate system and use that date a
tune wgs84 here we have also the
coordinates the latitude and longitude
coordinates and any date the un'
identification of the future where
modern and we have we have also studied
another standard k keyhole markup
language that firstly that was virtually
used by the product of Google Google
Earth and then was adopted as a part of
the d em LF is a specification KML is is
used why the for a wider community also
scientific community that upload
information over internet using came in
ville here we have an example of how
they o.o open geospatial consortium
change inflammation of the spatial
reference systems the second part of
this work is the construction consistent
in consists in the construction of a
topographical data model and for this
reason we have a study three of the most
popular flight simulators Microsoft
Flight Simulator flight year and explain
and also we have studied the standard
open flight to create and to sure scenes
between flight simulators and we have
built our model here we have a
representation of the high-level
information
I wear model was inspired main organ
flight but also has several feature of
the others topographic model and divided
the earth in areas each area is bound by
a coverage and has his special spatial
reference system it contains one or more
layers of information in the in our work
we have modeled tearing information and
weather information and also this area
could divided in in a vertical a grid
with the depending on that they level of
detail and each cell of discrete is
modeled as a tile and that I contain
information about extension of this land
also we could put information about the
projection we decide to use for example
Mercator projection and each area has a
model list and I put the other part of
the model in the next slide it's like a
model list contains one more models we
have model hot model only point based on
baited objects at the moment and each
model is composed by one more component
genetic components that has their own
local coordinate system and its bounding
box
and in this way we could model any
object without put the semantics of this
object into the model and each component
has its geometry and we could we could
have a mesh a life on face and if this
component use faces its faces its face
it can be excuse me can be applied in a
skin and this way dynamically the
appearance of the component could be
changed depending on the level of detail
it means the distance between the
component and the observer viewpoint and
we could adapt this skin of the
component yeah while we are flying there
the topography and well we have
implemented this model in geographical
database dura pickle database databases
allow us to to do special operations and
has special data types like a spawning
light string and polygons and has also
not an especial indexing and we have we
have chose a possible sequel for the
sequel use an is very special indexing
called a DI as T that is that is like a
art tree but
has another features improve it and we
have had chosen this poster sequel
database management system and its
tension post tis because it followed the
open Diaz standards and also allow us to
to set up and to change the spatial
reference system that will want you want
to use the third part of this of this
work is they integrate integration of
all this model data in a visualization
system for this reason we have to study
the previous work and there are few
previous works that integrate flight
simulators and geographical data base
and we can mention I can which they work
of mcdonald's at all and that is how it
has a eco flight simulator and
integrated with the application and can
explore the biotech biodiversity and
also google earth that in the version
4.4 point one of this product added a
flight simulator in this way a
anyone can a flight over the orifice and
a sinner is that ruler show us and this
is a very important point because what
we are trying to do is to build
integrated tools for visual to visualize
explore to analyze and to do a site
ities of this huge information and in
this way promote insight to other areas
like us earth areas of study our our
visual system was implemented using open
scene graph and that is a high
performance with graphics to make it
generate real-time scenes and its way it
is very used also to to implement flight
simulators and it was used in like year
open-source simulator a tad I mentioned
before and it is if this tool is very
sit on open to open Yale and Microsoft
is well as c++ c plus plus i use it i
have using microsoft's people d plus and
also i i i have used blender the blender
visual application to do the models and
to map the landsat images into the bore
fe and also
have used item to to import CRT em and
to do the interface between the systems
and this is a panoramic view now we're
approach we propose not only a panoramic
view because there are a lot of
application that show data into the
three dimension and but i will show you
the what is what what is it this this is
a tile of one day d by one degree
central in this latitude and longitude
it's a small area by a blanca city in
Argentina it was map um landsat-7 image
over the topography and the date and a
the data of the SR Keehan is the half
alley phoenician of free arcsec seconds
of latitude by three arcs seconds of
longitude and its model with a.w.s s WT
s 84 datum and with geographic
coordinates and also add there is a
layer of clay climatic information this
weather station we can we could see it
in the next slide here we have the
weather stations and this are because of
the day a small tile we have model and
these are fictitious weather station we
have not
many weather station in this zone and we
have this in this weather this weather
layer was modeled via using a Delaunay
triangulation we can choose in the
application the opacity and the the
level of subdivision of the weather
layer using a finite element method and
here we have the other you I I mentioned
for and this is this is a challenge try
to not only show the data and a
panoramic you if not i could not just
blow it this information this is a video
it has you know a low framerate now but
the application allah was to implement
the core of the assistant in chile keep
you and we hope to allows real-time
frame rates and what as a conclusion of
this work we can outline their the main
features the main results we have
obtained it we have defined a GM l
unified interface and constructed and
generic of genetics since this generic
flexible and extensible data model
generically because it's a louis to
model
generic a point-based objects and also
to define flexible because it's a low us
to define several layers it use it using
heritance to mobile the yellow years and
the geometries we can add another
geometries geometries and then the
poetry sequel database allow us to model
to implement this inheritance also and
we had constructed the 3d visualizations
application and added our flight
simulator to to begin to beginning a
twinning and they this this challenge of
show data and explore data in a
interactive and immersive standpoint
future works will be the integration of
other nutritionist data sources coming
maybe from KL because it without wider
community scientific community green
information convención de una unesco and
another's very big and important
communities and adding today we will
continue to adding another features to
the visual system and like us level of
detail and to a more realistic
visualization a multiple multiple
coordinate system and also new data
layers of information coming from
especially claim a data claim a data
source
like a swine and speed thank you very
much that is I had a question rated it
axalta I was a little clearer in the
beginning whether the system is being
used by environmental scientists today
whether moment it's a computer science
mm-hmm do you have people trying out the
flight simulator other scientists today
not yet no no no at first the project
began as a bigger project within
national agencies and then this turn to
a more green and research area and we we
hope to work more until or before bed
before to present this to maybe climatic
agencies or someone that could be
interesting yes yes it is a publish it
in the image processing group of the
computer science of the University of
Buenos ideas that anyone that everyone
but I want to would like to contact me
please just do it I can tell me more
information about it
one more parochial question local better
we have a member of history with the
flight simulator team in Microsoft in
the external research whether you're
connected yes yes perfect it sounds good
okay well I thank you very much thank
you thank you